Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first 1,000 people to click the link in
the description can get a free trial of Skillshare’s
Premium Membership.
Hi, hello.
It’s me again, Deboki, writer and occasional
host for Journey to the Microcosmos.
And I am here to confess something kind of
shameful to you all: the first time I saw
a picture of a tardigrade, I didn’t think
it was real.
I just remember looking at this animal that
looked like a cross between a dog and the
Michelin Man.
And it was even more strange to conceive of
how tiny it is, and that out there in the
world are just bits of moss with animals like
this one gliding through them.
Now that I’ve spent some more time in the
microcosmos, tardigrades seem almost normal.
Almost.
I mean, they are animals, and at the end of
the day, you don’t have to be tiny to be
a weird-looking animal.
But animals have the advantage of many, many
cells to build their different bodies.
On the other hand, unicellular organisms like
bacteria and protists, have less to work with.
And yet they manage to take on so many strange
and unusual forms.
Just think about it: if you were asked to
draw a cell, what would you draw?
Maybe your imagination is better than mine,
but I would probably sketch out a vaguely
round thing, maybe add some extra hairs on
the outside if I’m feeling creative.
Nature has a lot more clever ideas though.
Trumpets and spirals and floral arrangements,
all made out of single cells.
Of course, these shapes aren’t just for
fun.
An organism’s shape is connected to the
world it lives in, though sometimes the factors
shaping them are beyond our understanding.
It can be difficult at times to narrow down
why a microbe takes on a particular shape
when the reality of the microcosmos is that
in any environment, you can find a whole plethora
of shapes that might seem to have nothing
in common.
It’s also easy to look at the existence
of a living thing and assume that every detail
of its being has been optimized through eons
of mutations and selection for a specific
purpose.
And there is an extent to which that’s true.
The world places all sorts of demands on life:
the need for food, for reproduction, for warmth,
for light, for dark, for movement.
And we respond in kind by prioritizing and
balancing those needs, and shape is one way
we do that.
But it’s one thing to come up with stories
for why something might be advantageous, It’s
a much more involved process to prove it.
Take spirochetes, for example, which are distinctive
thanks to their helical shape.
They’re also…not great for us.
They’re infectious, able to dig into us
and invade our bodies.
And it’s been hypothesized that part of
how they do this is through that corkscrew
shape, which might help them move through
thick viscous solutions, you know, like our insides.
But proving this hypothesis took a lot of
work.
Scientists spent decades studying spirochetes
in viscous solutions and mouse stomachs, as
well as comparing them to other bacteria,
all just to show that this shape gives them
a physical advantage in colonizing bodies.
And even then there are still so many aspects
of the helical life and the advantages it
provides them that are still conjecture.
And that’s true for bacteria in general,
which can take on so many shapes: spheres,
rods, filaments, stalks.
But whatever the shape, the building material
is the same: peptidoglycan, a combination
of amino acid and sugar that links together
to form a strong lattice that holds the bacteria
and all its contents within.
The structure of the bacterial cell wall can
vary along with its shape.
One group of bacteria, called gram-negative
bacteria, generally have thinner walls and
an additional outer membrane.
Gram-positive bacteria, in contrast, generally
have a thicker, multi-layered wall.
But like many categorizations in biology,
this dichotomy is just a tad bit too simple.
One of the largest groups of bacteria are
cyanobacteria, and their diversity is even
more astounding.
There are cyanobacteria like the Merismopedia,
for example, that form flat colonies held
together by a mucilaginous matrix like this,
their round shape neatly arranged like candy dots.
And then you have other cyanobacteria like
these long filamentous forms that glide along surfaces.
Cyanobacteria are generally categorized as
gram-negative bacteria because their cells
have that extra outer membrane we talked about.
But cyanobacteria also have a thick peptidoglycan
layer, which makes them sort of like gram-positive
bacteria too.
And that strange combination of traits underlies
the spectacular diversity of cyanobacteria.
Single-celled eukaryotes, or protists, have
a wide range of exteriors too.
But much of our understanding of their shape
comes from their cytoskeleton, a network of
filaments and microtubules that coordinates
many essential functions in the cell.
And when it comes to shape, it might seem
unusual to focus on the amoeba, which is so
often known for its shapelessness, especially
as they move.
It’s hard not to look at a blob and think
of it as accidental, but the forming of pseudopodia--or
false feet--to help the amoeba move, requires
a complex architecture of microtubules to
support this shifting shape.
And of course, there are many protists that
take on very different shapes, whether
that’s for defense or for food or for some
other reason.
There are pediastrum, that form these spiky
colonies that protect them from algae eaters.
And then there are the Opercularia, which
look like little flowers attached to branches,
and whose cilia you can see at work gathering
food as it floats on by.
It’d be difficult to describe all the shapes
that protists take on because there are just
so many, even--it feels like--when compared
to bacteria.
Some scientists have argued that bacterial
diversity is more internal than external,
a function of metabolic reactions we can’t
see.
But protists have adapted more with their
shape, leaving us with a world where the diversity
itself is multifaceted.
We’ve spent this episode talking about the
diversity of shapes in the microcosmos, in
part because that’s what we can show you.
But we’ve seen over and over again the way
that shapes have misled scientists when it
comes to classifying organisms, or the way
that the shape of something can actually lead
to more questions that can only be answered
by studying the inside of the cell.
But that’s the joy of shape: it’s an entrypoint
into the microcosmos, a way for us to wonder
about organism and environment alike.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We’d like to also say thank you again to
Skillshare for supporting this video.
On Skillshare, you can put your new knowledge
of shapes to good use with classes like “Vector
Illustration: Design a Playful Character Using
Geometric Shapes” which is taught by Illustrator
Jonathan Ball.
From concept and sketch to creating vectors
and shading, you’ll learn how to start with
geometric shapes and ultimately end up with
something from another dimension, or maybe
even the microcosmos if you decide to create
your own illustrated microbe.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real world projects
to create, and the support of fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth.
It’s curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads to distract you,
and they’re always launching new premium
classes, so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you.
And an annual subscription to Skillshare is
less than $10 a month.
If you’re one of the first 1,000 people
to click the link in the description, you
can get a free trial of Skillshare’s Premium
Membership.
The names on the screen right now, those are
our Patreon patrons, and without them this
show would not get to exist.
So, thank you to each and every one of you
who support this channel.
We’d like to let you know that we’ll be
taking next week off from uploading, but we’ll
have a brand new video for you on May 31st.
And if you’d like to see some very good
microbes in the meantime, be sure to follow
our Master of Microscopes James Weiss at Jam
& Germs on Instagram.
And you can also pre-order James’s book
“The Hidden Beauty of the Microscopic World”
wherever books are sold.
And if you’d like to see more from us, make
sure to click that subscribe button.